he's been able to overcome every
obstacle every turn he's been able to
accomplish an amazing thing he will be
ready to play and be a star and uh he'll
do a great job he's an
amazing athlete he's got an amazing arm
he's got a great competitive edge you
know and he's got the ability to make
some great plays so you know the reality
is there's no higher level than what he
was playing at college
you know in terms of division 1a
football and he was able to do it play
at a high level and do it really really
well
that's russell wilson talking about
kyler murray on the mike tarico podcast
and some similarities between wilson and
murray wilson has to be happy that
there's a quarterback in the nfl shorter
than him even if not by much but the
baseball background transitioning to
football wilson has been one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl since he was a
third round pick in 2012 paving the way
for murray to even be in the
conversation to be the first overall
pick i don't know without wilson we get
to the point where murray is accepted as
a possible number one overall pick but
here he is chris and i think wilson
makes some good points about what murray
needs to do but you know whether or not
he's able to do it by the end of april
isn't going to affect whether or not
he's one of the first two or three names
off the board no it's not and i mean to
your point too i mean yes i don't know
if kyla murray is being talked about as
the first pick unless it isn't not for
russell wilson and i think the
combination of baker mayfield going
number one last year and a team having
the guts to do that and pull the trigger
there and then it working out for
everybody to feel at ease and like oh
okay we you can do this out there but
regardless kyla murray is a special
player he certainly is i mean there's no
flaw in his game i turned on the film
like i've told you so many times mike i
wanted to hate on him i thought you know
i try to go into film really thinking
that way a lot of times so i have no
preconceived notions about the player or
whatever it is but it's flawless the
only thing you have to concern about is
is the size and the wear and tear of the
season you know stats in the commercial
break brought up a good question you
know just one year of playing concern
you hey a little bit but it's not a deal
breaker he's still been around a lot of
football been around like guys like
cliff kingsbury when he was at or you
know and texas a m he was there behind
johnny manziel and some other guys so
he's seen a lot of football he's learned
a lot of offense and i think he is pro
ready
and mike
i had this conversation with my dad on
saturday i get the sense that kylo
murray is just playing it so cool right
now and just like he knows something we
don't know like baker mayfield last year
uh
do you think he already knows he's going
to arizona and he's just kind of playing
it cool and letting all this go out i
mean i almost get that that sense that
sometimes well i think baker mayfield
was playing it cool last year just
because that's who he is all of that
mayfield
mayfield i think knew what his floor was
but he didn't know what his ceiling was
he didn't know he was going to be number
one but he knew he was going to go top
10. i think at some point along the way
it became obvious to him
but i i don't disagree with the idea
that that murray yeah luck feels very
comfortable in something
and and and that's a a far cry from how
he was the week of the super bowl
because he didn't seem comfortable at
all i think he was either wrestling with
the decision of baseball versus football
or more likely wrestling with how to
properly
unveil that he's all in with football
and somebody decided hey let's act coy
about it and let's milk this and let's
draw and i don't think he's comfortable
with that i think he is who he is and i
think when he's able to live that way he
is more comfortable and i agree with you
i think something has given him that
comfort that peace that i did that he's
not stressed he should be stressed yes
he's not stressed and i think there's a
reason he's not stressed he knows what
his floor is and there's a chance his
floor is number one yeah well i mean i
think that's what the fascinating
conversation is about the quarterback
this year i mean yeah okay yeah
arizona won
if arizona doesn't take him at one where
does he go you know that's where i want
to go that's where it's so interesting
this year there's no team in the top 10
that is in desperate need of a
quarterback do the giants take him at
six i don't know what the hell the
giants are doing right now i'm not so
sure they're not bought into eli manning
for two more years like we talked about
last week when my father came on the
podcast so uh are they gonna pull the
trigger at six for for a franchise type
quarterback uh would they if they if
they did would they pull the trigger on
kyler murray if the if the arizona
cardinals didn't draft him you know then
you look at the next teams in the
conversation you go okay cincinnati 11
they're kind of sitting under the radar
here right now i mean
they got to be thinking of making a
quarterback switch at some point here in
the in this decade okay and then i look
at miami dolphins and the washington
redskins will they make plays to move up
how is it going to shake out but the
quarterback conversation as far as the
draft this year is as weird as i've ever
seen it because teams in the top 10 are
pretty much set up at the quarterback
position and i think that's what makes
it very intriguing we're going to delve
into that more deeply in the next
segment the teams that may be likely to
move around for now though with murray
one more cut from russell wilson talking
about calamari on the mike trico podcast
saying that murray is going to need to
work on physical and mental skills to be
as great as he can be here's more from
russell wilson
it's all about the study habits it's all
about the work ethic it's all about
the mental side of the game and he's got
the physical siding and he has the
mental side so when he puts those two
together in the national football league
like just like he did in college he'll
be a star and he'll be great
that that's great insight it's funny we
got the clip of of kyler murray doing
the drop back smile on his face flip did
you see that he's smiling he flipped the
ball
man the guy he yeah he knows something's
up he he i think he knew what he was
doing last week was just checking the
box doing what you do this is what we do
when in rome right i gotta go out here
and do this thing i'm not doing anything
but throwing some passes to my buddies
get a little sweat going get a little
workout in maybe have a little ice cream
to celebrate since i've you know he was
sweating like i mean i understand that
you're working but my god he was
sweating like crazy cardinals weren't
even there to make it look not so
obvious it looked obvious
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports